welcome back everyone
um here we transition from voting rights
uh to thinking about intergenerational
spatial uh inequality
um and I should note that we've had
um Dorian Warren was supposed to be here
or sent me his slides they were
excellent but his father has fallen else
so he's in Tennessee at the moment so we
will hope to get him back up here for
one of our other events
um but we are truly lucky to have a
great group of folks on this panel so
and a little bit more time for
discussion so thank you take it away
Jerry
good afternoon
I'm Gerald James I'm a professor of
economics and African-American studies
here at Yale
and um happy to
be able to uh hear some people talking
about any quality in various matters
related to that
outside of economics
I happen to be um regular particip
member of a
seminar Workshop
on
the topic of capital formation and
financial markets and things like that
actually but um
this will be something quite different
we want I want sure I won't be hearing
anyone saying anything about Edo
derivatives and recursive equilibrium
things like that so I'm really looking
forward to hearing what our speakers
have to say
and we're going to begin with Frederick
weary
who is a professor of sociology and the
co-director of the center for cultural
sociology here at Yale and he's going to
talk to us about
from economic liberalism to economic
Justice why conservatives get it wrong
and liberals mess it up
it sounds about right okay
so
um
so thanks again to best love for the
invitation and also to uh Jacob uh
hacker who reminds me of the 1971 birth
year was in fact an excellent one and
and so um what I'm going to do
um in the next 15 minutes or so is I'm
going to uh perhaps uh make a few people
uncomfortable
um in the sense that I'm going to start
out by talking about this quiet crisis
of people who don't have uh bank
accounts who pay too much for whatever
they do purchase
and who are really constrained in terms
of access to credit and what the
consequences of that are and one of the
arguments I'm going to make is that one
of the things that we find on the
moderate and conservative side is a
sense that economic freedom is
um at least friendly toward or sometimes
equivalent with economic Justice and the
evidence just does not support the claim
the other
problem is that among
well-meaning progressives there has
generally been a tendency towards
educating people financial literacy so
you educate them you graduate them out
of innovative social programs and they
see this as a reasonable Pathway to
economic justice but in this particular
course of Justice very few can see
salvation and so part of what I really
want to do is just just start with the
problem
um and
when we look and see that about one in
five
black and Latino households are
underbanked which means that even though
they have a bank account they have used
in the last year what we call
alternative financial services so
they've had to get the payday loan or
and those sorts of things that are
really very costly and then we also see
some pretty frightening numbers for the
recent who simply don't have a bank
account no actually it's 30 I'm sorry
it's 33 who are underbanked in the 20
percent
no bank account at all and sometimes
when I present this as a problem some
people say oh you're you're trying to
push people into formal services and and
Etc and it's not about pushing them into
formal services but it's about trying to
think about what the consequences are of
not having those kinds of services the
other thing too is when we think about
who lacks credit
and when people bring up issues of
credit it's not really that I see eyes
will glaze over very quickly in a
general audience and you have about
depending on who does the numbers some
people have estimated it as high as 60
million adult Americans in the US who
are not scorable
and so that means if you went down from
Florida through Georgia South Carolina
North Carolina and made your way up to
the District of Columbia and you took
those populations
a lot of people it sort of a assist if
an epidemic spread through this whole
part of the us and no one saw it
um and and it's often seen as this lack
of credit as a self-inflicted wound so
there's a sense that you know if they
were trustworthy
and if they didn't you know make
mistakes that any educated person who
can do simple math that they wouldn't uh
that they would actually have access and
so we'll talk a little bit about that
and the other thing too is we'll also
talk about what happens when you do have
credit but your family members do not
uh and so one of the things that we also
see is
the pressures to co-sign for loans
uh the pressures to then get loans on
behalf of family members especially if
it's a hard-working family member and
what you'll see it's what we see in some
of our ethnographic data is it was all
well and good when this person had two
or so jobs because the the income flows
are really volatile in a month so it was
when they had the two jobs or so
everything was fine hard working but
then once you either get a an illness
because you don't get paid when you're
not working
um if you're not like us uh so once you
get sick or what are those jobs
disappears that's when you have these
family members who had been on the ropes
um it's especially uh troubling when you
see this happening for young kids who
are U.S citizens what their parents
aren't
I saw the parents need to use Social
Security numbers to get utilities Etc
anyway so
why is this a problem
so if someone told you that
you want a house you want a house you
both have steady employment
the house is a hundred thousand dollars
but you know what you're gonna just have
to pay a lot more for that same house
and that house will appreciate in value
at a slower rate
you would say Injustice
but that is in fact what happens
if you're even looking for an apartment
to rent so we're not even talking about
people who are well off enough to try to
buy a house you just want to rent an
apartment
I don't know about the last time you
tried to rent an apartment but often now
there's a credit check they want to see
your credit score and so one of the
things too and so the the person's name
on the front slide I should have said
this earlier
Jose can Jonas and I are doing a lot of
work together uh he's the executive
director of mission asset fund and so
when I get towards the end I'm actually
going to talk about some work they're
doing and work we're doing together but
so and this is a case that they
encountered there's a mission asset fund
you're trying to get a house an
apartment to rent
you don't have a credit score for
whatever reason even though you can put
down the deposit you either can't get
the apartment in the better neighborhood
or you need to pay a lot more down
or the deposit to get the apartment
and so you're basically paying a lot
more of the same goods and services than
others similarly situated citizens
making similar amounts of money with
similar levels of education and
sometimes when you're looking for a job
they're also looking towards your credit
score to see if you are
trustworthy uh
and so we then move from the situation
of thinking about jobs and freedom to
thinking about jobs credit and Justice
and so here we're thinking about the
people who may have the same employer
and they're doing everything else more
or less the same but it's just simply
that one has a decent credit score and
the other does not
and when you talk to people about what
it means to have a decent credit score
or not you know you hear lots of stories
about having a sense of dignity and
things you have to do if you're you know
care about your family it's Easter so
what was I supposed to do it's Christmas
of what was I supposed to do you mean
that you hear these stories
and when people think about budgeting
and financial education
often you get this Narrative of
its simple math it's arithmetic right
and so one of the things I remember from
the Democratic National Convention is
when it was time to ridicule the
Republican Party Bill Clinton stood up
and he said but it's simple math
and in fact often when people who are
trying to access Credit or have had
troubles with their credit in the past
they will tell you that same story it's
simple math
I should have known better therefore you
know you're not gonna you don't see this
whole mass movement of people saying the
way I'm being scored is somehow unfair
or the consequences of my score are
somehow unfair because I did it to
myself it's a self-inflicted womb I
somehow lack virtue and so here we see
um Jennifer Hulk shield in in the in a
guinea 2004 piece talking about sort of
this notion of individual effort
virtue leads to success
success is evidence of virtue we return
to Vapors Protestant ethic and the
spirit of capitalism
you are responsible for your own flaws
and so much of what you see is an
emphasis on letting markets work and the
way we let markets work well is we say
make sure they're educated this is
something that both sides agree on
get that Financial education in there
remove legal barriers clarify
information choice choice choice
uh and so there's and therefore a record
Edition that okay you're going to do
better
there's still going to be a high uh Inc
like Gap because even if you're doing
better and the people who are doing
better than you are doing better and
you're kind of increasing at the same
time
okay inequality is just what it's just
what we have to live with but you're
going to do better mathematically
speaking much better
um but what we don't do is we don't sort
of try to figure out how people Define
their own needs and why they're
selecting the strategies of action that
they do and so here again economic
freedom is not
economic Justice
but then what you also see
financial literacy
and so you know when we hear literacy
who doesn't want to promote literacy
I mean the general notion is knowledge
is power it's what we often hear
and sometimes I have to say there's a
reason that the word knowledge
is not the word power
one of these is not like the other
and so they're the and they're often
these very rigid ideas about what it
takes to be declared financially healthy
um and a focus on teaching people how to
manage numbers
and very little attention to the extent
to which people are really managing
relationships and so when you don't see
a whole lot of financial instruments out
there that allow people to manage their
relationships and the sense of ritual
and social obligation
uh and a more risk responsible
or at least something that can be read
as responsible way then there's an
emphasis on
you know once you get your education you
need to graduate get sort of like
graduate get out get out of my house
you're on your own
um and so you have these socially
Innovative programs and what they'll do
is they'll say if people have
participated in your program
why are they why are they still coming
back for more of these in this case
lending circles
their credit scores are they're doing
much better why they still want to do
this
they've graduated okay
um so there's not an understanding about
why people use the services that they
use and what the other functions are
those services and then there's also
this other push on protection and so one
of the things that I will say is that
yes we do need some protections there's
a lot of predation out there predatory
lenders Etc
what we also need is more competition
for the kinds of
borrowers that they target
and so what you'll see at the very end
of my 15 minutes is uh Senate Bill 896
in California in which they without any
objection
they said it got passed last August
Jerry Brown signed it in not a whole lot
of fanfare not a whole lot of coverage
and all it says is that if you are a
non-profit and you want to provide a
loan of between say 500 and 2500 which
is that range where people are generally
going to the payday lender and you're
going to provide a low like a no
interest loan
with just a fee attached to it
you don't need to go through all the
regulatory Hoopa law to do that
you are now exempt from up from all
these Finance codes
which is what the mission asset fund
needed they have been in close contact
with Lou Correa to get this done they
got it done done very quietly
and without opposition because it looks
and is Market friendly
so
there are so on the at the same type
that I'm saying we're messing things up
there are some things that we in general
are getting right okay
and part of the way we get these things
right is that we go looking for
existing practices and beliefs and
rituals and we try to discover the
informal Advantage so what are people
already doing but they're not getting
credit for
Mission asset fun
so
Jose Quinones
he said he says
you know they their people are always
complaining about how do we know that
this is a a good bet for a loan how do
we know that they're going to pay it
back
um because they're not showing up in the
credit system at all
but we do know that in our communities
there are lots of people who get
together in groups of say 10 people a
hundred dollars on the pot every month
one person gets the lump sum of a
thousand dollars it's informal but
everyone knows how it works people are
comfortable with it and they are doing
it even when they have access to formal
banking services so why don't we take
practices that demonstrate your
responsibility and credit worthiness and
somehow formalize those practices
he got
Jose's kind of he's yeah he's he's great
great and interesting because he
believes in sort of Partnerships and
having collaborations with people that
have unfor at first glance she would say
oh the the
ugly enemy
right
he went to the credit scoring agencies
and Experian and Transunion said
okay
we will let you report these repayments
on loans as repayments on social loans
these people are now getting these
positive dings on their credit report
per month and all they have to do is oh
if they don't have a bank account they
have to open up a bank account keep it
open for at least six months because all
their payments into the circle have to
be done electronically the lump sum has
to come electronically
they also have to collaborate at the
beginning of the circle give their
Circle a name talk to one another talk
about financial strategies figure out
that they are not idiots and in fact
they actually know quite a lot about how
to manage their money given their
circumstances
and if you don't get the number that you
want for the month that you draw your
loan because if you get it near the
beginning it feels like credit near the
end it feels like savings you then have
to appeal
have a conversation with the rest of the
circle about why you should have your
number your moment in which you collect
the the lump saw moved up or pushed back
you were then given a lending instrument
that resembles what you would see in a
standard lending instrument so that you
can figure out what are the things I
need to look for Etc
and it's something that you're
comfortable with
you're doing it anyway
so this was the this is one of the
Innovations
and after 10 months on average they saw
an increase in credit score of 168 they
saw people's
um
uh overall debts go down
and so far the last I guess three or
four years they've made about 3.7
million and loans
so they are they are launched
again as they were doing this they
figured out we need regulatory Clarity
to keep the momentum going because they
had other people who were interested in
maybe doing this but they said
we don't want to run a file of the state
regulatory Clarity comes at 896.
and then a pause
and so where the pause comes in is we
have a social Innovation that seems to
be working
but what we're also discovering is that
the way people think about their
financial needs is really different than
what the non-profits and the foundations
are telling them that about how they
should be thinking about their money
and so how do we rethink
needs
and how do we sort of assemble these
into some kind of
uh structure in which we can think about
how needs are being met both with
government programs private sector
offerings non-profit offerings so that
we can bring together partners
who on first glance really ought not
even be in the same room
and really shouldn't even consider
themselves as being viable partners
we won't go through this thing because
we're still working on our pyramid
oh and and that is another that's
another challenge another paper
and so
I actually timed this for 12 minutes and
I think I'm right on it 12 to 15. that's
it yeah no yeah every now and then I do
something right
oh there you go see you see there see
there you go okay so yeah yeah the
Victory lap came a little too early
that's not the first time I've done that
okay
so in conclusion uh in conclusion uh so
one of the things that uh that I just
want to and press on all of us is that
uh
the consequences for not having credit
uh and for not being able to link into a
bank account are pretty severe but these
are consequences that for the most part
people blame themselves and their and
and no one wants to talk about it and
they end up paying a shame premium
uh in order to evade shading so much of
what's happening is you're seeing a lot
of stigma management strategies to evade
shame and people paying a huge shame
premium
um what we're also seeing though is that
and I didn't know that this was a thing
fintech Financial technology companies
out in the Bay Area are working very
hard to try to think about how people
are mixing and matching
um and trying to develop new new
Financial tools to capture what they see
is this new market
that is somehow emerging the other thing
that we're seeing is that places like
the mission asset fund are also
targeting that moment in life in which
you are really coming into your own
financial aid college students and so
for the dreamers so that with the with
the app to try to bring in
um to try to defer
uh
what do they call it deferred action
for college students they have a special
program for dreamers so that they get
the application fee
through the lending Circle
but they get the check ahead so
everybody gets it at the very beginning
The Lending Circle so that they are then
routing them into healthier cochlear
appropriate financial services and
helping them find social support so so
they are looking for a number of
different ways for thinking about what
are existing practices
that are culturally appropriate that are
legible in those communities and how can
they be adapted in order to
we're not going to get rid of but we can
somehow better address
economic inequality so with that
I think
okay next let's welcome Maya Wiley
Council to New York's mayor de Blasio
advises him on policy and administrative
matters
among other things in civil and human
rights and gender equity
so brave people who ask an attorney to
speak for 12 minutes but I I will do my
best uh and of course I'm not an
academic so I will try not to
I so I was saying to Pat like I was so
embarrassed that I was going to be on
this panel with Pat because usually what
I do is I just cite his work copiously
and then look smarter to the public as a
result
um so uh okay but at least
so at least I get to talk first and I
maybe I'll cite his work and not say
it's his and then
um so I I actually thought I wanted to
start since it is Black History Month
with
um
actually with two sorry
with two quotes from James Baldwin
that I wanted to use to frame what I'm
going to say one is that people are
trapped in history and history is
trapped in them
and the second is it's certain in any
case that ignorance allied with power is
the most ferocious enemy Justice can
have
um and the reason I link those two is
because when we talk about inequality I
mean first of all there's the history
the the the history being trapped in us
part of his quote is really about how we
don't even really understand inequality
I mean so we use the term constantly hi
Lonnie
um we use the term constantly and we
actually are always talking about
different things
sometimes in the same conversation as if
we're talking about the same thing so if
we really you know right now the
conference hi Kika the understanding
about inequality is is is generally
based on income right and we're having
this conversation about inequality is if
they're really two groups who are
unequal one group is those who are the
one percent and then there's the other
99 percent
and that's kind of shaping and and it's
come to a very race neutral definition
as well as a gender neutral definition
and misunderstands that actually from a
structural standpoint we've just been
hearing some of the examples of that
from a structural standpoint we actually
have multiple kinds of interactive
inequalities
uh and that it means that as a result
depending on who we are where we are
where we live we all may experience some
form in that 99 of some form of
inequality compared to someone else or
some other group but it could be vastly
different whether we are a construction
worker who is Irish Catholic Living in
New Jersey or whether we are a single uh
Latina mom who is undocumented living in
Birmingham Alabama right I mean those
are not the same kind of inequalities
even if they experience inequality but
the history wrapping in us we've kind of
said well we're done with race because
we have a black president so we're
good on that and that at the same time
what we really have to address is income
and sometimes we talk about wealth more
more often we talk about income
inequality
and that we actually rarely are willing
to look at what's happening structurally
often that is historically produced that
has gotten us there and I'm not going to
talk a lot about the historical part
because first of all most of you all
already know it but the the relationship
then to the second quote which it is
certain in any case that ignorance
allied with power is the most ferocious
enemy of justice is that we are also in
a context in which power has become
increasingly concentrated in private
private hands corporate hands where
corporations are given and considered to
be people personhood and in a context
that then shapes our politics and our
power at the same time we have over the
past 30 years because of our success has
been demobilizing communities
so that's people
power and then the policies that shape
opportunity so I I'm saying all that as
a backdrop because in 12 minutes I can't
say all of what I mean by that but
Lonnie said it at lunch so I don't have
to which is that we have a series of
policies that started if we look at the
first just to summarize it so we all are
you know what I'm talking about what you
do which is in the first half of the
20th in the basically from the 1930s to
the 1960s we essentially created tons of
policies
that invested in people and created for
the first time in middle class but it
was not a racially equal middle class it
discriminated in job category it is
sometimes explicitly discriminated
sometimes ex it had could just
discriminate by virtue of the fact that
it could just say well if you're a
domestic worker or an agricultural
worker you don't get Social Security
benefits so all of those things
essentially created a middle class for
the first time in this country but that
was not a an equal middle class right
and it did not look equal and then
created suburbanization and so
everything all the inequalities were
looking and in addition and one fact
that's very important um uh particularly
for legal historians if you look at the
14th Amendment which was one of the
Civil War amendment that its entire
purpose essentially was to create
citizenship for black Americans uh post
slavery
and if you look at Supreme Court case
lawn this is the work of professor
Charles Black what he found is that the
vast majority of cases before The
Supreme Court asserting First Amendment
protections were asserted on the behalf
and to benefit corporations not black
people
um and I said that's a really important
thing to understand when we look at the
fact that now so many Americans
experience inequality in a context
of of private concentration of wealth
and power not just in a few
people when we think about the one
percent but it's actually what the top
tier of that one percent represents in
terms of corporate power and corporate
wealth so fast forward to then why uh
what we so because I'm going to try to
be positive having just been really
negative
um and and I want to frame it a little
bit and what that then looks like into
current today
um context because in New York City when
you're in a city which one is the
largest city in the country you knew
that right but did you know that New
York because I actually didn't I like I
knew it was big and I've been living in
it for decades but I actually didn't
really think about the fact that not
only is it the biggest and the most
diverse it actually is as large as the
next three largest cities combined
so Los Angeles Chicago and Houston if
you put them all together they get to be
as big as New York
which is an astounding thing when you
think we are literally eight percent of
the the Metro areas the eight percent of
the country's gross dramatic domestic
product
so when you're in a city government with
a mayor who has and actually a city
council by and large a majority of the
city council says we are committed to
eradicating inequality
in one of the most diverse cities as
well as the largest city in the country
thinking about the power of local
government to start to think differently
about how you dismantle inequality in a
current context is actually
potentially and I'm not arrogant enough
to say we're going to get there but
potentially a transformative moment not
just for New York City but for the
country
and just to give you a little bit of
sense of what how much inequality
despite numbers right because we all
know where demographics are going so
there's this assumption in the
conversation that if people of color are
no longer in the numeric minority then
by definition the country will become
more Equitable
um
and we know that's not true because we
all have heard of a country called South
Africa but put that aside take New York
City right and I just want to give you
just a couple of examples because I
think they're relatively shocking and
I'm going to use gender because I think
we we often also erase what it means to
be a woman of color and and low income
but if you look at for instance
60 of low-income mothers didn't have
paid sick leave
um and the difference between having
paid sick leave and not having paid sick
leave it can literally be whether you're
feeding your family at the end of the
month I mean quite literally putting
aside whether you can amass Savings of
any kind uh and most of those women are
women of color because if you look at we
have something we I in my previous
organization was called Jim Crow jobs
which is we have racialized segmentation
of the job market right so of the 30
fastest growing uh job sectors in the
country it they're actually very
racialized and six of those fastest
growing job categories like nurses aides
and home health aides literally are
predominantly over 50 percent women of
color
and they pay less than poverty wages
so
um and then if you add domestic violence
on top of that and I think this is
really important as we're talking about
Public Safety so often 40 of all felony
assaults in New York City and 33 percent
of all rapes are domestic violence
related
and if you look at about 24 about a
quarter of the City's population in our
lowest income communities
are 40 percent of our domestic violence
cases in the city
now that isn't because rich people don't
beat their spouses but it is because
there are in in there are built-in
economic inequalities that also Foster
the conditions for domestic violence
right
um so I say all that just to frame it a
little bit in in real terms um and if
you look at our homeless population we
have literally constructed homelessness
for women who are beaten because the
solutions become that they have to leave
home and by and large they're not
exclusively but when we're talking about
low-income women in New York City they
are buying large women of color but it
also means the economic conditions for
their families including for those men
are often that they are unemployed and
also in very Stark economic conditions
and as Pat's work shows we actually see
where we have communities that are
extremely low income traditionally even
for families that are at the top end of
the wage categories in those communities
their children experience downward
Mobility economic Mobility so there are
conditions of the community not and and
that's for a lot of the structural
reasons that I've just described but
what can a city do about so I really
want to frame my remarks about what a
city can do about it because for one
thing we spend 70 billion dollars a year
70 billion New York City spends 70
billion a year so one question that
we're examining is how can we utilize
that money to ensure we're hiring women
and minority-owned businesses every time
we spend that money because we also know
from the national studies that if you
want to hide make sure that low-income
people who are in high poverty
neighborhoods are hired they're much
more likely hot to be hired by
particularly minority-owned businesses
and literally something like 70 percent
of the jobs in this nation are created
by small businesses anyway these are
largely small businesses comparatively
speaking so they're huge economic
benefits for individuals and by the way
they tend to then have health benefits
and all the other things that create the
possibility of having assets they are
actually there's a multiplier effect not
just in terms of the business owners
themselves but in terms of the workforce
and then the community building that
happens because of where that Workforce
tends to be located and it's a good way
to do it because the Supreme court has
also interpreted the Privileges and
amenities of clause to say we can't say
explicitly that you must hire locally
if you are to get a city contract now
there are other things we can do to
pipeline local Workforce into jobs that
we are creating and we're doing that by
First Look programs where we're
requiring contractors who are going to
be hiring to First Look at folks that
are coming out of city-funded Workforce
Development programs it's not a
requirement that they hire them but it's
another example of the city using its
Contracting power and that 70 billion
dollar leverage we have because there's
no other there's no other way low-income
people have that kind of capital
leverage right but if Government deploys
it with low-income and highly
impoverished and excluded communities in
mind we can potentially do something
very different and the other thing is
obviously the policy itself so
bus Rapid Transit lines was one of the
things that we're going to start doing
to connect communities that have been
disinvested in terms of public transit
to get to job centers again not a small
thing because if you look historically
at policy decisions where we prioritized
Highway spending over public transit yet
the vast majority people of color are
not in cars comparatively speaking
especially in a city like New York but
not even just New York but we have not
significantly invested in the public
transit options for for some of the
communities that are also the lowest
income which is one of the reasons why
they continue to be the lowest income so
to actually invest in the public transit
lines that are going to connect them
through bus rapid and to make it fast
right because for the vast in this
country literally two-thirds of
low-income people
traveled 90 minutes or more to get to a
job
and that's because of where people have
to live because of housing costs and
where jobs are located and the lack of
investment in the transit that connects
them
you know and then finally I'll say you
know in addition to obviously we're
doing as much as we can on minimum wage
and prevailing wage in New York City we
do not have the legal authority to
unilaterally wait raise our city minimum
wage where Albany has to do it and
that's where power comes in because to
have an Administration that's actually
closely Allied not just to labor but to
the progressive left generally
politically means the kind of political
organizing between
citizens and their institutions and
government around contesting with other
parts and more powerful parts of
government to do the right thing which
is part of why Governor Cuomo has now
agreed to raise the minimum wage to 13
an hour when he when it was stagnating
at nine right and that's higher actually
than what the president originally
called for
that brings me to my last point which is
at the end of the day there's even
cities and even cities as powerful as
New York and one of the great things
we're also going to prototype by the way
Child Development accounts which if you
if children have as much as 500 in
savings for they're like three times
more likely to go to college than if
they don't so that asset problem in
communities of color in particular is
one of the things that also mirrors the
just on affordability the access to
education Gap so our our we are
literally have fundraised the money to
ensure that we're going to Pilot tens of
thousands of kids in a three-year period
getting Child Development accounts so
that there's money there for college
which is going to help a lot of kids who
otherwise will not have that now none of
this is sufficient
and I think that's a really important
thing to admit none of this is
sufficient at dealing fully with
inequality but it does show the power of
of local government when it has Will and
we have will not just in City Hall but
in city council which creates a powerful
block to do a lot right because we don't
have a lot of opposition from our city
council sometimes they even can push us
to do some stuff we might not be
thinking about doing but it doesn't end
the fact that we actually lack in this
country a meaningful Urban agenda
and if you think about it the last time
we really had any kind of meaningful
Urban agenda was the war on poverty and
that was fairly short-lived and at the
times that we have had the most progress
in developing more equality is when we
have had significant national attention
and programs on attacking it and on
supporting state and local governments
as well as others to do it so one of the
things I will leave you with is at the
end of the day it's not just important
whether New York City is doing the
number of things I've said which I think
are actually
excited and about and meaningful for
low-income communities of color in
particular and will help everyone who's
low income it's that if a city the size
of New York does it
and has an active Allied relationship
with Advocates who are outside of city
and state and federal government
and that other cities start to do the
same things and develop out of it a set
of Demands and strategies that are both
argued for by cities as well as by
Advocates and organized communities we
will actually have created an equation
that could potentially demand the
National Urban agenda we need to
actually address inequalities knowledge
forms and that's the real opportunity we
have right now that is my hope and that
will help us eradicate the in ignorance
that stands in the face of Justice
okay next let's welcome Patrick Sharkey
associate professor of Sociology at New
York University
so I'm really honored to to follow Maya
it's been it's been remarkable to see
what's going on in New York
um and really inspiring and fun to hear
about it uh
directly here
um
so okay so
um let me get to it the the
uh what I'll focus on kind of sits in
between this panel and the next one
um I think I kind of decided to do it
this way because I don't think you can
really talk about racial inequality and
some of the themes that I'll talk about
on space as well without bringing in a
discussion of of Criminal Justice policy
and the car soil State as eventually
referred to it earlier
um so I
I'm Gonna Make Five Points I'm going to
be very abrupt and and we'll probably uh
Breeze through some of the data that
I'll show you
um but I'll try to explain it the the
punch line even if I don't go through
the graphs in detail uh and the the kind
of basis for the entire talk is that
when we think about racial inequality we
really have to think about it as
organized in space okay so Space by
space I mean cities and neighborhoods
space has been the key way not the only
way but let me soften that a little bit
one of the major ways that racial
inequality has been organized throughout
the history of this country and that's
really been uh true in other places in
the world but it's it's particularly
true in in the U.S context
um so I'll give some just some a little
bit of data to make this point and then
and then elaborate on where I think this
takes us and and the comments about kind
of the absence of an urban agenda is
really kind of central to where I want
to end up uh thank you I appreciate it
um
uh so just at a basic descriptive level
um making this point that racial
inequality uh is really uh organized in
space organize the wrong space along
spatial lines
um you know the first point is that
black and white American children and
everything I'll say is black and white
and that's because
um a lot of what I'll say is about
multi-generational patterns it's not
because uh every other group is uh
irrelevant it's because I don't have the
data to make the same kind of concrete
claims I can make about
African-American and white uh
families who have been in the US for
multiple Generations okay so it's a
limitation of the data source
um
uh black and white American children
continue to live an entirely different
social worlds a shorthand version of
this graph is at about two-thirds of
African-American kids uh live in
neighborhoods with at least 20 percent
poverty compared to about six percent of
white kids uh this this neighborhood
inequality is multi-generational half of
of uh Black American families who have
been in the U.S for multiple Generations
have lived in the poorest quarter of U.S
neighborhoods for consecutive
Generations okay so that's true for
about seven percent of white families uh
what this tells us is that when we look
out
um in New Haven or New York or or
wherever we are and we look at families
that live in very disadvantaged
neighborhoods the disadvantage that we
see the inequality that we see should be
thought of as a continuation of
inequality that's been experienced for
at least two generations okay so
persistent experience of life and highly
disadvantaged neighborhoods
um four out of five black children who
are being raised in high poverty
neighborhoods are from families that
have lived in similarly poor
neighborhoods for at least two
generations 80 percent okay this has
very little to do with income okay so
this this graph just looks at the
average neighborhood conditions of black
Hispanic and white households
and this is a scale of neighborhood
disadvantage okay so higher means worse
means more concentrated disadvantage
unemployment welfare seek joblessness
um
these are the these are the the features
of neighborhoods that go into the scale
okay and the one here is one standard
deviation above the average neighborhood
in terms of disadvantage okay uh so and
then this is classified by income groups
this is black white and Hispanic
households making less than thirty
thousand as black has been white all the
way to families making a hundred
thousand dollars and above so you can
see the racial gradient racial and
ethnic gradient at each level of income
and then the comparison uh that is is
usually surprises people is that if you
look at black families making a hundred
thousand dollars or more they live in
more disadvantaged neighborhoods than
white families making less than thirty
thousand dollars per year okay so this
is the severity of racial inequality in
neighborhood environments and it really
is very little to to do with income it's
a longer story about how to explain this
um
which I don't have time for
um but we've actually made pretty good
progress I think um uh explaining these
these patterns
um okay the second claim inequality is
driven by conditions in majority black
neighborhoods so the distinction is is
in thinking about this as an individual
or family or household level issue
versus a neighborhood level issue
um this this graph shows the lighter
shade is is the percentage of
um uh Black American families
uh living in sense it in neighborhoods
that are both disadvantaged and
surrounded by spatially disadvantaged
communities okay so in the heart a very
disadvantaged sections of urban areas
um so if we look at black families that
back in 1970 more than 70 percent of
black families were in these very
disadvantaged neighborhoods surrounded
by disadvantage other disadvantaged
neighborhoods that has dropped okay
there's been Improvement it's about 45
now okay still massive racial
inequalities if we look now but there
has been improvement over time this is
just whether the family lives next to a
tract a neighborhood that is intensely
disadvantaged okay meaning more than two
standard deviations above the national
average so I think these really high
poverty concentrated joblessness areas
that percentage has dropped from around
just under 50 percent to let's see just
about a quarter okay so there has been
progress in terms of where black
American families live there has been no
progress in terms of the conditions of
black neighborhoods okay these are
majority black neighborhoods these show
the same figures what do majority black
neighborhoods look like in 1970 well
about 85 percent were disadvantaged and
surrounded by disadvantage over 60
percent were shared a border with an
intensely disadvantaged neighborhood if
we look now the the percentages are
about 82 percent and just over 60
percent so no change in the condition of
majority black neighborhoods when there
has been change it is it has arisen from
black families moving out of majority
black neighborhoods that has been the
primary mechanism for advancement into
neighborhoods with less uh concentrated
disadvantage okay why did this happen
well this is uh my started to talk about
this uh in kind of thinking about this
I've drawn heavily on vessel's work and
there's a more elaborate argument uh in
the book but the shorthand version is
you know if we go back to the war on
poverty if we go back to the late 1960s
there were kind of two narratives about
the
growing Urban crisis and that was a
crisis of increasing joblessness Rising
crime
social unrest okay the wave
of riots that spread through uh cities
in the 1960s growing pollution all the
problems that we associate with Central
cities really started to emerge in a
major way in the 1960s
and there were two narratives for
explaining this Urban crisis one was as
a function that the crisis was a
function of persistent inequality an
oppression okay and I think that
probably was the dominant narrative at
least in legislative terms for a good
chunk of the 1960s
the second narrative was that this was a
function of criminality and lawlessness
um and a lack of respect for social
social order that was concentrated in
urban ghettos okay this was a very clear
and this is where Vegeta's work has been
uh so helpful just tracing the roots of
that Narrative of the urban crisis and
the links that were made very explicitly
between life in central cities
particularly in urban ghettos the
connections to race and the connections
to violent crime okay those connections
were made explicit in political rhetoric
they were made very explicit in the
consciousness of Americans okay this was
a time when crime violent crime started
to be linked with with protests of All
Sorts with the civil rights movement
and with social unrest more more
generally and this narrative has
dominated Urban policy since that point
I don't think that's an exaggeration to
to make that claim that the solution if
this is The Narrative of the urban
crisis the solution was the prison okay
the solution was a policy of Abandonment
um and Punishment
okay and since that this is not the only
legislative response but this is the
dominant legislative response since the
late 1960s this is our Urban agenda
since the late 1960s okay
um so again that's that's the bad news
the um this is explanation for why you
know when African-Americans have made
progress It's by leaving those
neighborhoods that are the object of of
Abandonment and Punishment as an urban
agenda okay
um
now the the positive development and I
think it's an enormously positive
development is that there has been a
dramatic and sustained and very real
decline of violent crime over the past
20 years
um
this is measuring the violent crime rate
the peak there is in the early 1990s but
all this policy this narrative about the
urban crisis was happening in the run-up
from the 1960s through the early 1990s
this is what we know about Urban poverty
what we know are kind of the dominant
model of urban policy was was developed
in this period where violent crime was
Rising this was connected to civil
rights this was connected to race in the
central cities
this has reversed okay so violent crime
has been cut in half uh the murder the
homicide rate has been cut in half as
well it
data from long ago aren't great but it
may be the case that we're in the safest
period of our country's history at least
measured by the homicide rate so this is
a very real development the most violent
cities have changed the most okay led by
New York in Los Angeles
uh
the the drops in so I should explain
this a little bit so this this is just
the homicide rate 93 and the homicide
rate in 2009 and essentially if if there
was no change in the rate over this
period then then the city would fall in
the 45 degree line okay so all the
cities on this side of the line indicate
that crime has declined okay so the fact
that there are all these cities on the
far right here that are far away from
the 45 degree line means that the most
violent places have changed the most
okay the most violent neighborhoods have
changed the most okay so this graph is
just this is St Petersburg Florida now I
show this because
this pattern shows up in all the cities
that we've been able to get data for an
extended period of time where there is a
drop there's usually a drop across the
board in all types of neighborhoods so
this is the least violent set of
neighborhoods back in in 2000 in this
case this is the most violent set of
neighborhoods
all groups of neighborhoods have had a
drop in crime the most uh the sharpest
drops have occurred in the most violent
communities and this is true we we
looked at six cities this is the first
study that's been able to look at
neighborhood level crime over an
extended period of time we looked at six
cities this is true in every one of
these cities okay the largest drops in
crime have occurred in the places that
were most violent okay what this means
is that
or at least the way I'm interpreting
this is that the meaning of urban
poverty has changed in central cities in
the place and not every city has
experienced a drop in crime you saw some
cities that were on the 45 degree line
in the places where crime has dropped
the meaning of urban poverty has changed
okay very quick demonstration of this
this shows just the average rate of
community violent crime for the poor
population of the city and the non-poor
population of the city the Chicago
Cleveland Denver Philadelphia Seattle St
Petersburg Florida not a random sample
those are the cities that we could get
data from
okay this is at the start of the period
so we're tracking the change of violent
crime over time this set the start of
the period the difference between the
average community of the poor and the
non-poor this is at the end of the
period okay so what this tells us is
that there's been a convergence poor
people continue to live in more violent
neighborhoods but there's been this real
compression this convergence of the
experience of poor and non-poor people
this has been true uh for racial and
ethnic groups as well so these these uh
columns show uh the average neighborhood
conditions for whites blacks Hispanics
in these six cities okay this at the
start of the period this is at the end
of the period okay so there's something
in Chicago there's still huge racial
inequality okay racial inequality hasn't
been overturned it hasn't been
eliminated but it has been weakened
um
in uh in Denver there's no difference
between the average communities of white
Black and Hispanic families it's not
adjusting for anything okay just a
remarkable change in what it means to be
poor what it means to be a member of
African-American Community Hispanic
community in these in these places where
crime has dropped substantially okay
um so uh
what this means to me is that there is
now space to imagine a new Urban agenda
I think the connection between central
cities race and violence which was
solidified in the early 1970s and became
a dominant theme of American politics
and American policy perhaps made
solidified even more in the 1990s by
democrats okay this is not a right-wing
model this is this is the dominant model
of of urban policy for since the the war
on poverty since the early 1970s this
connection has been weakened
considerably okay and I think what this
does is it gives space to imagine a a an
urban policy agenda that will replace
the prison as a primary tool to address
Urban inequality
um the if I can say one last thing the
the um
how we do this I think is crucial right
now I think there is momentum from both
the left and the right to confront mass
incarceration
um probably more momentum on the right
than the left right now at least in
terms of legislation in terms of uh
uh you know potential uh political
actors who will confront mass
incarceration at the federal level at
least
um I think progressives have
rightfully spent a tremendous amount of
time arguing for decarceration I think
that effort has to shift to really focus
on investment and integration the kind
of stuff that New York is doing the kind
of stuff that we heard about that's
going on in Connecticut that should be
the really strategic I'm not a political
scientist but I'm happy to be in the
room with all of you who can tell me if
I'm wrong or not but I really think this
should be the primary emphasis of
progressives not to focus attention on
decarceration but to really focus on
what's next investment in integration
all in there
questions
I am absolutely thrilled to have heard
what everyone has to say and I want to
ask a question that maybe all of you
have something to say about I want to
link it to what Lonnie said in her
question earlier in the early panel and
then maybe some other comments
um during lunch and so
I guess I'm going to start with
Patrick's Point and sort of ask the
question I looked at all the data and
it's very compelling but as being on my
political scientist had I think of two
things and you may have an answer to
this I just wonder as I looked at it we
know two things are true I used to live
in Los Angeles and the downtown area
which nobody used to live in I did
because it was close to work and I liked
living
is now revitalized but what's happening
hand in hand with that revitalization is
right the influx of capital the out Flux
Of people of color and poor people and
you know the overlap of the two and I
think of you know you can tell that same
story in any number of other cities but
I wonder
and I try not to be too cynical about it
is the renewed attention to an urban
agenda
in Parks Bird by or perhaps in service
to Capital coming in
and not reaching these big questions
that we're thinking about so when you
talked about all the shifting
communities and the dropping crime I
mean one way of looking at that is you
know things have been made better
because programs have been effective
another way and I don't know you may
have an answer to this is people were
just pushed out so that you know the
problems that they experienced not their
problem people but people with problems
are just moved to a different location
so that a conversation about an urban
agenda may look differently because the
people there are no longer or the people
that we are concerned about are no
longer there in large part I guess it's
leads to the last part and I'll shut up
um if our goal is integration and this
gets to a lot of this point earlier I
wonder about the research that talks
about those moments in neighborhoods
that were integrated they're fleeted
relatively speaking right they don't
last long because it just takes one or
two families that are white with capital
to move out and it tips over and becomes
you know a lot of the things that we
think are troubled about neighbors that
aren't necessarily places where there's
a lot of capital and you know I'm sure
there's a much more complex story than I
just gave but I do wonder if our goal is
having an integrated city a city that
has capital is that possible given our
politics so that was a lot but I'm
pleased to any piece of that yeah great
question so let me let me just clarify
my use of the term integration and I say
this without explaining how I'm how
amusing I mean it to specifically
thinking about mass incarceration so we
have a huge population of people who are
coming out of the prison or otherwise
have been involved in the criminal
justice system when I talk about
integration I mean integrating
that massive population back into
communities
um and it's a small number of
communities that are absorbing so I when
I say integration and investment that's
really what I meant as opposed to kind
of the traditional notion of racial
integration uh in in neighborhoods um I
think so a I'll I'll say you know the
the changes in in crime I think are real
in the sense that it's not a population
shift I think we can say that
confidently I think the um
the other piece of your question is
crucial so the question of are we just
setting up neighborhoods that are
comfortable for Capital uh again and
what are the implications of that
um
it's certainly true when when crime goes
down this the stuff I'm doing now looks
at all these other dimensions of urban
life and how uh whether crime reductions
in crime have a causal effect on these
other dimensions of life like voting as
we talked about earlier but also like uh
families with children moving back into
Central cities from the suburbs so
spaces change in the way that we would
predict when crime goes down and this is
wonderful I mean this is this is
tremendous news for people who like
cities uh City public spaces are are
thriving when crime goes down for
everyone in this community now there is
this challenge about how to allow the
families that have been in those
communities to remain there and to enjoy
the the
new public life that and I think Maya
probably has much more grounded ideas
about this than I do because we're not
working on this but I
think it's a really interesting
I I
to kind of put it pull it out of its Uh
current I mean we we tend to think about
these questions in relationship to
what's happened in the past rather than
to think about them in relationship to
the massive shifts that are happening
that we could take advantage of if we
were to think differently so I think the
way you pose the question is interesting
because it's sort of based on since it's
not I mean not oversimplifying being
reductionist but but giving we've seen
fleeting and tipping integration in the
past and the fact that Urban policy from
urban renewal to now the return of
capital and actually pushing low-income
people of color in particular add to the
suburbs so there will become Paris means
that we uh that we actually that
integration may be the problem rather
than thinking about the different
opportunities to think about stable
community stable communities that look
more like the world
given some of the shifts now let me give
you a couple of examples of I don't have
the full answers but I I will say that
an effective National Urban agenda is
not a list of discrete policy demands
and I think that's what we tend to uh
including me sometimes right fall back
into easily is what are the three
specific policy things that if we won
would change everything well we have to
have some wins
um but I think the mistake we make is
thinking that the vision is that there's
some specific policies that get won
rather than thinking that what we're
actually contesting for is a United
States that's radically changing
demographically and radically changing
in terms of the challenges of everyone
thriving including the opportunity now
is including the Deep wealth divide and
the fact that some of the fastest
growing economic sectors are actually
young people who want integration I mean
this is we have to really put some of
our generational stuff aside right now
Tech sector is the fastest growing I'm
taking New York but every other city in
the country is trying to compete for
Tech sector jobs there's a reason for
that it's because Tech sector is not a
sector It's actually an economic
ecosystem and for every Tech sector job
you're create getting three more jobs in
the economy and that the tech ecosystem
actually tends to pay for the non-tech
job
for the non-tech job more than the exact
same non-tech job not in the tech sector
which means if you actually think about
what that so which is why cities are now
competing with one another to try to get
that sector but that sector
that sector is actually both politically
more aligned with us and extremely
interested in living in very diverse
Urbane environments and this is actually
a shift in what is happening with where
we see some Capital growing and I think
one of the one of the things we miss
sometimes is um because it's because
it's in a different category right Tech
sector like
like I can barely use my multiple
devices but
um it's and it's not just New York it
affects in fact Silicon Valley now
remember New York is I am getting on my
hobby horse now but New York is but but
racial Justice groups miss this because
we don't see it as race and this
fundamentally is race if you think about
what's happening right now
so Silicon Valley is the number one Tech
sector in the country right no surprise
there no one bees right New York is
number two right now they're trying to
figure out how to hold on to their
diversity so they don't lose their Tech
sector
that is a major shift but it's a it and
the other thing I have to think about
it's not just an economic shift that's a
social and political shift but we have
to think about how we organize into that
and that means both how we organize
thinking about our Urban agenda and our
policy demands as well as how we think
about what capital is ours or how we
take and deploy capital in ways that we
can and it's it's even created some
interesting opportunities even sometimes
with large corporations uh after I said
all that pillaring stuff about large
corporations
um but their stuff Google will do that
Verizon never would okay so we we we we
have to think very very differently I
think um not based on our experience of
the past but really looking at the
actual transformational shifts that are
happening now that we should be taking
ownership of and figuring out how to own
yeah Google supporting blending Circles
by the way they're one of the many
supporters but the other thing too that
we sometimes forget supported net
neutrality
but the other thing we often forget is
that when you come out of prison
and you're trying to get stable housing
and you need to get put down a security
deposit
you can't do it right um and so they so
so we really don't have financial
instruments and practices for people who
were formally institutionalized either
in prison uh the foster care system etc
for them to then start more stable lives
because every time they they try to get
started they just can't really do it and
so there are sort of some discussions
about developing new types of lending
circles for the formerly incarcerated as
ways of getting them now scorable into a
system so that they can do some of the
same things that other people do so this
is a an ongoing challenge
Joe
I've been extremely moved by by this
panel and and I I have a couple of
things to say and then a question to ask
uh what I want to say is that I have
just finished reading a book that I
think is going to be along with uh The
Wealth of Nations and Happy Town one of
the most often mentioned and least read
values
I just finished reading Pekingese
capital in the 21st century and I must
say that it does have in its data set
just a great deal of information
by race and by ethnicity with regard to
the economic condition of different
categories of Americans
what shocks me about this panel was
Professor Sharkey's comment namely
pikony shows that the United States of
America has jumped way ahead and by the
Alice in terms of how rapidly we are
making our society more unequal
we now lead the pack
the astonishing thing about it is that
unlike what has been happening in Europe
where because inequality is growing
there as well
unlike Europe
our inequality seems to be created
by annual return to wages as opposed to
Capital
the reason for that however happens to
be if I may say so
it happens to be New York City
because this is the place in the United
States where we are still creating these
perfectly astonishing
levels of return to work as opposed to
Capital
so we
how would you explain
this is a question for you I would do it
how would you explain this prop in
violent crime
simultaneously with this astonishing
growth in inequality in the country I
grew up in Chicago my my and I grew up
in a very marginal
sub-module let's put it straight I grew
up in the slum
uh if if the violence rate in Chicago
has dropped it's got to mean that there
are that
that something like what has happened in
Manhattan is going on in Chicago namely
the centers of this city which were once
places where you had a lot of violent
crime are being gentrified and therefore
poor people who live there are leaving
and so I think it may be misleading
that graph that shows this drop in
violent crime if the data is true of
urban America and not just your six
cities then what it says to me among
other things is that we desperately need
an ideology that we've never had that
would address the issue of inequality in
ways that none of our political parties
historically ever has
so
let me let me handle a vinyl crime part
the other part is is someone else out
there and they have a point of
clarification on the crime rates are
those age adjusted per 100
000 or are they just per 100
000. they're not those are not ages not
age adjustments those are neighborhood
level rates
okay yeah so you
but you know when you look at the crime
stats so
I'm trying to think of what the best
best one to make the cases
um it's your model is you know with
complete respect is is not right okay so
it is not that neighborhoods have
gentrified and crime has gone down what
has happened is that crime has gone down
among the most among the poorest
Americans the rate of victimization for
the poorest Americans is lower than what
it was for the richest Americans 20
years ago it has gone down in you know I
showed you
um uh most among uh
African-American and Hispanic people
both in terms of perpetrating crime and
being the victim of crime it has gone
down the most in the most violent places
and in the poorest communities I accept
that what is the reason for it so there
has never been a strong connection
between
economic inequality and crime
there has not despite what sociologists
in the 1980s
passionately argued there has never
crime in the 1960s that was the last
truck
um that that
period was when you know that that was a
point where you would have thought that
crime would have been very high it's
very low okay same in this last
recession crime went down okay so
there's never been International level
none of the local
because obviously you just told us the
opposite okay
you're saying economic inequality at the
federal level and crime versus at the
local level because there is association
between
there was an association as opposed to
meaning Divergence as opposed to
individual level economic
right outcomes affect do absolutely
affect so individ there's there's
evidence that individual level
um economic need affects property crime
right uh there's an association between
violent crime and poverty uh that's
undeniable but but the the mechanism is
is not
to understand crime one should not make
the case that the need for uh that that
it's instrumental uh in terms of
economic interests
um that is is wrong so when we when we
look at the crime drop of the last 20
years and this is not settled you know
but I I have a chapter on this in in the
book I'm writing which the argument that
I've settled on is that a you know
people will get very upset for me for
saying this but incarceration has
reduced crime okay
inefficiently
um we are arresting you know way too
many people to get the kind of drop in
crime uh that it's produced but the most
Progressive uh people studying this have
have argued that uh the rise in
incarceration has reduced crime by at
least you know 10 to 25 so that has been
a contributing factor okay the vast
scale up in terms of uh police
departments uh and uh and the
Improvement in police tactics and there
has been tremendous Improvement even
though there's still you know horrible
uh oppression the Improvement in police
tactics meaning use of data meaning
expansion of community oriented policing
has contributed to the crime drop and
the third factor and this is where
um I think the story has not been told
clearly enough the third factor is that
the communities that were hit hardest by
violence in the 1990s organized on a
large scale to control and confirm front
violent crime in their own communities
and you see this anecdotally in a lot of
the qualitative literature but I just
got a full database of non-profits and
you look at non-profits and in the 1990s
there there were very few anti-violence
organizations at the local level in the
1980s like in a couple hundred by the
end of the 1980s in the 1990s it
exploded these were organizations
sprouting up in the neighborhoods that
were hit hardest there was a mass
movement to confront violent crime and
it was a serious problem I mean very
young kids were killing each other in a
way that had never happened before okay
there was a large-scale movement
academics don't know about it because
most academics don't live in the
neighborhoods where it happened
including obviously myself
there was a large-scale movement to
control violent crime okay and I think
that combined with these other factors
which if we're being intellectually
honest we have to acknowledge that
incarceration can contributed the
increase in in federal money for
policing and state money for policing
contributed and the movement within the
neighborhoods hit hardest uh overwhelmed
that's my argument that they came
together overwhelm the problem
so stop and frisk is a great thing no
it's not stop in prison down the street
in New York is trying to get a tax in
New York I can't do it I I think stop
and frisk is is oppressive well and
actually the statistics show was having
stopped stop and frisk we've actually
seen no increase in the crime rate which
actually demonstrates that stop and
frisk is not right I think what's been
effective is knowing exactly where crime
is is uh the times and the places where
it is most prevalent through data and
being able to Target it now the way it's
been targeted I'm you know I'm actively
working uh in New York
um on this issue and I think everyone
there acknowledges that the way it's it
has created
it is oppression and you know it has
also led to a reduction quality of life
for young black men
and many many law abiding young black
men with this walk down the street of
New York a couple years ago he stopped
and messed with and college students
land against the law again
and and and living your life
great yeah
I just had a comment which is related to
the new Urban policy and that
celebration or maybe it's just on a high
technology I mean any it seems to be any
Urban agenda for the future has to deal
with the competition between cities or
sectors like high tech which just
strengthens the hand of high-tech I mean
they can Google can do X Y or Z but if
it's extracting concessions from cities
to an urban agenda
of zero-sum competition between cities
it's always in the interest of cities to
do that if they think they can win but a
National Urban agenda is cities coming
together to demand that the federal
government create Federal programs that
invest in people so Urban agenda have to
be willing to sort of get that up right
like your testimonial willing to give up
so I actually think that's a false I
think that's a false dichotomy is uh I
don't I mean in other words I agree with
you that there's too much and I actually
think it happens much more on the
subsidy side than it's it's the subsidy
side problem right I mean the truth is
New York people pay
Tech sectors not locating New York
because New York's such a great place
for Tech sector to locate for financial
reasons Tech sectors locating in New
York for all the reasons why New York is
a really cool great place to be for the
tech sector so it's actually being
attracted to New York not for that
reason and Michael it's cooler than
Sohan Valley because that's they're
actually and more Global and more Global
because that's actually extremely
important to the tech sectors to be
Global and to be in a global City so I I
say that and it's actually a particular
segment of the tech sector it's not all
Tech sector right so it's like it's the
apps it's the but my I guess my point is
I absolutely agree with you on the
subsidy and Taxation side because and
and and I think one of the reasons the
cities that's structural the cities do
that is because there is no National
Urban agenda which so first of all
cities for instance New York we can't
unilaterally raise our tax rates we have
to go to Albany which means yeah I mean
those kinds of structural conditions
actually sets up and creates the
conditions for the com zero-sum
competition if you have an effective
Urban strategy and it is part of the
design of the urban strategy the point
was only that you had to have that in
the urban strategy some kind of that's
critical because otherwise you're going
to be in a situation where the power of
Corporations which you sort of alluded
to at the beginning is only reinforced
well and the truth is cities can't do it
alone in fact cities have to be held
accountable so which is why I said you
know it has to be it has to be a larger
strategy than just saying if cities get
together politically and do something
together the demand it works that's not
that's not the political science of it
right it has there has to be a there has
to be uh there has to be a citizenry
that's demanding an urban agenda but
where cities actually are an extremely
good political leverage because there
are a lot of cities willing to align
around some very aggressive stuff and
let me just give you one example that is
not this is a I am I am throwing this
out as a possibility not a prediction
but one of the emerging movements out of
the out of uh the progressive left is
for non-citizen voting
now that is a political non-starter but
you know what so is the abolition of
slavery so uh I think the issue is if
you actually think about those kinds of
organizing strategies and demands and by
the way there are cities I think over
time that will start to think about
passing that at City level if they're if
they're able to stay Progressive just a
few but those few are really large and
once they've created some possibly
created some political cover on that
this is a scenario not a then actually
what you do is you create so much more
political power because if you look at
the changing demographics and how much
of the voting block is not engaged
because it's undocumented you actually
have the potential to actually change
with some of the demands are and I think
that's why it has to be it has to be an
aggressive
non-governmental strategy but thinking
about where there is leverage within
what some local governments will be
willing to do that becomes a synergistic
relationship and that's all I'm
suggesting I'm not suggesting cities are
the end-all be-all I'm not suggesting
they are the silver bullet and I'm
certainly not suggesting that everyone
should sit back in their seats because
there's some Progressive marriage in
some large cities who will get it done
I mean because but I will say and I I
say this in complete not our honesty
that to be in a situation we're meeting
with Boston mayor Walsh we're meeting
with Los Angeles mayor Garcetti I mean
when you meet with the it there is
something different happening in large
part because of what's happening in the
country politically because inequality
is so damn bad
that it is created a different
possibility of what large City Mayors
are willing to say and do that is more
Progressive and more aggressive than two
years ago and that's really my only
point about the opportunity and and it's
not on all things but if it's on the
right things in conjunction with people
what people are demanding outside of
cities it really could produce something
very different
um we are actually out of time
well we can go I think um because we
have a break till 3 30. I wouldn't
actually mind getting a few more
questions and going I'm sorry dear
that's fine
can we can we all agree collectively
that
um maybe take take five more minutes or
seven more minutes
thanks so much this is really
fascinating and uh
I'm hearing about the sort of network
the mayoral networks the mayor's talking
about American cities is really
interesting but I was wondering on that
graph actually we've heard a lot of the
great stuff about New York but
Cincinnati is the one yeah that is the
outlier although the yeah crime is
relatively low right and it's increased
so I was wondering if we've heard about
some of the strategies that New York has
taken is taking now what what is it that
makes Cincinnati
doing the opposite yeah well I think I
mean Cincinnati is an outlier there in
the sense that crime's gone up a little
bit at least in those years I was
looking at um I think you know
Cincinnati had this these very severe uh
uh riots and racial tension uh
derived directly from police brutality
cases I think that was in the early
2000s so I think that local history
um is does anyone from Cincinnati here
could speak to this um
uh you know I think I think the issues
that we're seeing now
um in New York and Ferguson and
elsewhere uh were happening in
Cincinnati in the early 2000s on a
pretty severe scale
um so it might you know that's my only
kind of uh knowledge of what's going on
in Cincinnati that would that would
speak to that but it may just be that
they had a very tense and unproductive
relationship between community and the
police
because Chicago in the last three years
had enormous crime rate
and and I just wondered
um relative to the you know in the short
term they've had a spike uh relative to
1995 crime has been cut in half or so
yeah
um at least by the homicide rate on the
homicide so Chicago has gotten much
safer in terms of homicides Chicago
still has a very high crime rate and
Chicago probably has the most severe
inequality uh across neighborhoods
although even that has has converged
there's there was a blog post that got a
lot of attention
um suggesting it hadn't but um uh there
was actually a correction by the by the
guy who wrote the blog post we got the
data wrong
um Chicago has had a convergence uh it
but still I mean the degree of
inequality is very extreme yeah
I'm aware
of walking because if you look around
your University of Chicago is located in
all of the Suburban you know small
suburban areas and then you go downtown
Chicago it's like in a different country
and so I was that's why I'm surprised
when you talk about the drop in crime
rate because when I you know what I
understand you so you know there's all
this outrageous thing in the last couple
yeah but I mean the point you raise is a
good one that they're you know we
shouldn't be content with the level of
violent crime violent crime is still
incredibly concentrated in space and
there are communities you know where I
could present this and you know get
laughed out of the room because
it's a very violent places
this may be a question for mine in
particular but maybe all of you have
things to say about it
um
in a policy prescription to what extent
if anything does the attention to the
public school system have to do with
this equation I can imagine their
politics that
are their own animal that you probably
don't you know they're people that don't
want to get into it at all but it has to
be I mean as a topic as a political as a
possible element of an urban agenda but
also a part of the problem that one
might see as linked to questions
involving violence and stuff yeah no no
I think it's it's hugely important
um I think the the
I would actually argue for a variety of
reasons that housing is more primary and
I think that's for several reasons if
you look at the two biggest
expenses for for for people that become
completely prohibitive for low-income
people is housing child care
um one aspect of that is we are dealing
with impart in part which in the city
not nationally which is universal Pre-K
and that's that's a that's a partial
because at least it takes care of you
know six hours a day you have hopefully
a quality I mean we are pushing for a
quality program free and guaranteed seat
for your four-year-old right so that
that actually is takes care of a couple
of years of the child care Gap
potentially for people so there there
really is an economic benefit that as
well as an educational benefit
um the reason I say housing is because
first of all there's such a link between
what happens in schools based on housing
and and that one of the problems we
actually see very little National
discussion or traction on is housing
because when we talk about
gentrification why people are pushed out
as capital is coming back into cities
it's housing and it's housing policy and
it's housing cost so you if you have
public housing authorities which and I
mean this isn't just New York this was
New Orleans this was this is a lot of
cities where now when Capital starts to
come back some of the only ways that
guarantee people's ability to continue
before the neighborhood or those in
subsidized housing those are those are
in public housing except that we've been
disinvesting in public housing for two
decades so actually most housing
authorities are in the red which then
creates a situation in which cities are
thinking about how they privatize their
public housing stock so unless you
actually have a very aggressive strategy
on talking about how you create and
subsidize housing so that there's
housing affordability particularly as
capitalists returning you're just we're
not going to have an effective Urban
strategy but it also enables us to
connect housing to also how we do
schools right because there's such a
there's such an interconnection between
housing and schools less so for a city
like New York but New York's an outlier
on that what what is more complicated in
the conversation on education is
charters
and and it's complicated uh for all the
reasons we all know right which is a
large constituency in communities that
for some of us who may argue against
Charters uh because of the way we fear
its impact on public education some of
the very people who are impacted by that
argue for Charters and there's a lot of
division
and it's it's not there's not an obvious
race class division here there are lots
of low-income people of color who want
Charters and there are lots of folks who
don't uh so it's a hot they're highly
contested issues about what an urban
education agenda looks like once you
take investment in it out of the
equation I think there's a lot of
consistency around investing in it and
we need to put more money in it but not
what the it is
um so so I yes the short answer is
definitely yes
um
but I think given the some of the
complexities around how divided we are
we are actually less divided around
housing and particularly given the sub
crime crisis and a range of other issues
around affordability that it may be it
may be one of the entry point policy
areas to in order to get it at education
more effectively
okay
yeah one of the things that I was taught
by practically talking and also uh about
this possibility for a new Urban agenda
which is like incredibly exciting but
then I was thinking back to Keith's map
about 70 of this case being dominated by
the Republican party and we also keep in
mind that the Republican party now has a
bit of a movement the tea party which
um is
um
let me feel sort of go back and forth
there's no way around the fact that it's
very racially infected and um so
um and so
um so that would seem to standard way up
into urban in general
in other words you're finishing up this
book it says we're at an historical
um juncture where opportunities are
opening up and then you're just telling
us that in New York City we're actually
pioneering a model using New York to
make advantages and the exceptionalism
of New York so that can create a
portable model and so I just think it's
between two of you and it sounds like
you also do talk to each other
follow them on Twitter
who would not
no one who's smart
well I so I this is a really important
question so first I actually
um the Tea Party Movement itself is a
deeply complex movement and it's not a
monolith uh and I think that's important
because while it was wildly successful I
think we've also seen cleavages within
it uh and a tendency then to think about
it as being bigger than what the it
might be right that I think there's a
core that is and it's actually the very
ideological and racist core and then
there are a whole bunch of folks who
identified with it uh but for a variety
of different reasons and and the reason
I say that is it what it we did we did
one overlay comparison at my former
organization
um after after the recession where we
where we met just because data was
available because some great group did
some great stuff and we could overlay
subprime and race on top of it but what
we found is in is in districts that were
that were Democratic that flipped to
Republican because a tea party right the
Tea Party organizing that those places
had really high hard hit by the subprime
mortgage crisis and in in in there were
actually places that didn't flip
same demographics same demographics but
didn't flip Tea Party
and the reason and the and the
correlation I mean we can't say it was a
reason but the correlation was the way
they were not hard hit by the subprime
crisis
um which actually was this isn't like
perfect social science but it but but it
actually did speak to something that
that many of us believed which is the
amount of energy
that's beyond that core that hard core
of the Tea Party is was about economic
insecurity and the way it can be
manipulated by race uh and the context
the reason I say that those we did not
contest hard I mean we've been
demobilizing communities in a lot of
ways for a lot of reasons so I think
your question is really important
because not because the Tea Party is in
is infallible and because we can't beat
it it's important because what it really
points us to is the fact that our
institutions of organizing and
mobilizing have been deeply weakened uh
and are deeply fragmented I mean both
the what's happening in the union
movement being the most obvious but it's
not exclusively the union movement but I
think one of the hopes is that we've
also seen an increase in organizing and
commute low-income communities of color
at the same time that we've so part of
what we're seeing is the opportunity to
start to bridge where we have had
traditional labor organizing that has so
often been so important to winning
electorally and and pushing policy
because they're large and have money and
then they can spend
um with the fact that this non-unionized
and vastly fast-growing population it
tends to be low-income communities of
color are now being organized and trying
to find partnership with unions so I
actually think where it points our
attention to is how do we actually
rebuild uh the apparatus on the left
that is multiracial that is multi
multi-issue right that's not fragmented
by issue that is demanding that because
that's really what the Tea Party
represented
that's really what I put the put aside
the multiracial that's what yeah that's
what the Tea Party represented right
which was multi-issue but it organized
around the principle of no taxes
uh we need an organizing principle but
we also need an organizing apparatus
although as the culturalists on the
panel I just want us to be very careful
not to sort of go too deterministic from
the sub because they're made so yeah
there's so much we don't know about the
characteristics of those demographically
similar neighborhoods where you do have
the subprime versus where you don't have
it and the other thing we don't know too
is what what is the experience of
inequality right so the one the
difficulties is that we we have all
these metrics about why why we think as
academics that inequality is so awful
but what we really don't know is the
varied experiences and how they cluster
um in communities that have very similar
Financial uh fundamentals um and and
that's so I just want us to be a little
yeah you know this is you being an
academic and me being an on the ground
so I mean because I know I think this is
on the ground
okay
no no it's a strategy issue yes because
the question is what do you have to
know that's really my point
because I think one of the one of the
things that happens in the debate
between and this is multi-generational
because I remember my parents having
this fight with some right which is
where we say we think we know enough
about what we need to experiment and try
in terms of cleavage and and organizing
opportunity versus what we can what is
knowable
um based on the research we can amass
around it so I think what ha that's
where that's it's a healthy disconnect
right it's a healthy tension not
disconnect that's the wrong way it's a
healthy tension
um and because one of the things I think
has started and is starting to change a
little bit and I say this having come
out of the Walk World
um so believe me it's it's it's that
um so much if particularly if we look at
where we've seen successful social
movements so much of it has just been oh
hell let's just go try this because we
see things happen we're strategic and
formed like we see what we think are
opportunities and we're just going to
now try to lean into this that's all I
really need
um and the the research behind it though
is really really important just like
this I mean everything in this
conversation about what the research
tells us and doesn't tell us is also
really important because it's how we
kind of mine the educated guess yes but
the social Innovations we study are is
that's how that's how researchers lean
in and so yeah we sort of look for these
opportunities of oh this London
so we're closer yeah so we're actually
closer than we sound
there needs to be a lot more of the use
in there because I promise you that
there are a lot of academic circles oh
yes oh yes and I've seen it yet and
that's I mean no and I say that because
I think you're absolutely right and
anemia to be more applied in the way it
does research and that would also be a
tremendous leverage point for
development strategy
it's more that they ain't enough to use
around yeah that's the problem so I will
take the last word with the caution
and that is that we keep in mind
that um for a lot of
slip thinking people inequality is a bad
thing
but typically for people in the United
States inequality is not a bad thing why
inequality is gaining in traction right
now is because of two things
we have growing inequality
combined with
tremendous stagnation in the middle part
of the distribution and then I might add
real Devastation and about the bottom
quarter of the earnings distribution so
we've got inequality of the worst
possible kind Rich getting richer and
the middle and poor deteriorating
and what we want to keep in mind is that
our first objective has to be to try to
think of
policy alternatives to help the second
part of that not inequality per se now
that Pro those policy Alternatives will
of course attack inequality but we have
to keep our eyes on the real prize
so we're finished for this